all right let's talk a little more about
the Middle East let's talk about Israel
Palestine we can probably knock that out
in just a few minutes and everyone will
be satisfied right okay so 30 seconds 30
seconds let's do it so I thought maybe
the best way to do this because I do
know how much you know about history
where should we start with this because
what I'm noticing lately is that you
know as we're seeing the stabbings and
the shootings in all this the debate is
rarely about what's happening right now
but now the debates starting to be I the
Partition pant plan ah the British
Mandate like now it's starting to be
unfurled
and people don't understand history as
we alluded to earlier so where is a good
place if we're gonna have a decent
discussion and try to get some common
ground here where is a good place to
start with with the Israel Palestine
situation I think the only place you can
start is from where we are really and an
acceptance that on the part of people
who are broadly anti as well and
acceptance by those people that Israel
exists and it's not going anywhere you
know I've spent a lot of time there and
in surrounding areas and the West Bank
and so on and spoken with a lot of
Palestinian representatives and so on
and one of the saddest things is when
you hear them talk about the occupation
and the discovere they're talking about
the occupation from 1948 because then
you say you know what you're you're
giving your future generations no hope
you're selling them a lie you're telling
them that we all get back Tel Aviv you
know we'll get back the whole of
Jerusalem we'll get back - and so on
it's not going to happen there's they're
bigger they're selling their young
people a crock yeah and and I think it's
a tragedy if it's if if they accepted
that Israel's not going anywhere and
Israel felt confident enough that the
Palestinians accepted that then the
negotiations for the border dispute are
frankly quite straightforward
you can see that you can you can see
them on the ground you can see where
basically you know the Israelis of won
and basically where the Palestinians of
won and you can see that you know the
the basis for what's often be called the
world's ugliest border ah but you know
you have to start from the premise that
is was not going anywhere and and I
think it is one of the most striking
things that in 2015 so many debates on
college campuses in the media and so on
don't accept that fact and you know if
we had a conversation about Pakistan and
and we started by saying you know should
Pakistan have being created or not as a
mistake we wonder if we could rectify
this error you know people would say
what are you talking about it's 2015
Pakistan's got all sorts of problems we
need to talk about but why are we
talking about this this is this is a
problem from seven decades ago you'd be
a maniac but but but on Israel if that's
thought quite normal Israel and Pakistan
are the same age and these these crazy
Israel obsessives keep going back to the
basis and they're not gonna win
that's over that's done so what do you
make of these people so cuz I see that I
see very clearly I try to tweet as much
stuff as I can about coexistence I want
there to be two states for two people
and understand that people can't live in
occupation and I want everyone to be
treated with dignity and have the right
to self-determination all that but I see
nothing except on on the left all I see
is just this relentless demonization of
Israel no matter no matter what they do
look they left Gaza there's not one Jew
in Gaza Hitler would love the place
right yeah yeah no you'd feel right at
home in certain ways that yeah um but
but the problem is that by the way when
you say to say the two-state solution
doesn't exist it's dead it's gone the
best you can hope for now is a three
state solution because it's in no one's
gift to unite the Palestinians right so
I want it I wanted to ask you about that
too because it really is a three state
solution yeah I mean people should stop
using the tooth two-state idea um but
you then have to ask some serious
questions about the negotiating partners
on both sides now people like to say
here and again the clever thing to say
is well you know six of one half a dozen
of the other and so on it is simply not
the case that the
Israeli Prime Minister uses rhetoric
about the Palestinians like Palestinian
moderate so-called moderate leader
Mahmoud Abbas is used in recent weeks
about the Jews uh you know Mahmoud Abbas
was talking about the we were we don't
want the filthy feet of the Jews on our
holy sites I mean this doesn't even get
very much coverage outside of the region
and you know if Benjamin Netanyahu had
made a speech where he said we don't
want any filthy Muslim or Arab feet in
our land
I reckon that would have made the front
page of the New York Times you know I
think it would be being discussed I
think people wouldn't know about it
Mahmoud Abbas does the most
extraordinary incitement than the most
extraordinary an aggression and and all
all that allegedly right-thinking people
in the West can do is to say this is the
man with whom you must do peace because
he's not Hamas um I think that the world
should should concentrate less on the
israeli-palestinian dispute you know I
think it's a it's over egged it's got
too much attention on it
none of the attention helps there are
intractable problems around the world
the siharan question the western song
question Cyprus all sorts of ones and
and actually a massive amounts of
international opprobrium and attention
do nothing to solve these conflicts you
know that we have seen in recent years
that the the motif of our time fall
apart in the Middle East and that was
and it was said by everybody from light
a little from right and left throughout
my upbringing at any rate if you could
only unlock the problem of the
palestinian-israeli dispute the rest of
the Middle East will be solved I heard
this few years uh you know some of the
israeli-palestinian border dispute and
the economy of Yemen will boom and the
Iranians will see the point of gay
rights and the Saudis will understand
you know the potential utility of women
in this society
it was obviously nonsense then but we've
seen it's nonsense in recent years we've
seen it because the Middle East has
managed to fall apart with zero Israeli
involvement yeah so is that the bigger
issue
here is that sort of that we're really
talking about a three-state thing
because Gaza and the West Bank are
totally separate ruled by different
people and there's no reason to think
that if a BAS signed an agreement that
Hamas would abide by it I mean in their
in their you know their what do they
call it their Charter it says kill all
the Jews so they're not going to
suddenly change so they're so that's the
strange part as I see people in the West
saying well you know just make a
solution make a magical solution and
they'll stop wanting to kill you but it
doesn't seem like there's national for
those people it's not about the Middle
East they've been Manning most of
people's cattle never been there they
don't they don't know anyone there it's
about them goes back to that point I
made the start it's about them if use if
you say how concerned you are about this
situation you come across as virtuous
and knowledgable you'll see idiots way
out right and yet there's one place in
the Middle East that stands for their
progressive values and that's the place
anytime now and now they use the
progressive values against it we're told
that if you highlight the fact that you
know that in Israel gays have every
right at one and in every other country
in the region you get hanged people go
it's a detail why are you bothered why
why are you pink washing why why are you
doing this has bara for them you go no
actually you know for me it's not a
detail I mean I mind whether I'm hanged
or not I mind whether all the gays are
hanged on are I mind what their views
are on a whole range of things I mind
there's a difference between a society
in Israel it's actually talking about
what you do about IVF rights for lesbian
couples and a few miles away a lesbian
lesbians don't get a look in on the IVF
treatment or anything else I mind about
that these aren't details but all these
things that used to be the things we
used to say well what we used call the
things that matter are now brushed aside
as bi don't you bore me with all that
all that all that all that all those
facts so you keep coming up with